hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus carlsen chess
uh tour yeah it's uh magnus crosstown
again with the white pieces against
hikaru nakamura this is the first game
of their sixth match hikaru won the
fifth match
and uh well now hikaru is leading three
to two in matches and if he car wins
this one then hikaru is the overall
winner and he wins the magnus cross and
chester if not
uh then uh the result will be a tie and
we will get our match seven
uh so let's see what happens here
already it's an extremely crazy game
right right from the start so magnus
like yesterday goes for d4
sorry about that we have uh knight to f6
and c4 by magnus we have e6 and the
knight to c3 again inviting the nimzo
indian which hikaru goes for
and e3 now just going for the for the
traditional line e3 and queen c2 are the
the most uh well well basically the
oldest continuations uh
so testing hikaru's preparation in the
main lines with castles and
bishop to d3 we have c5 by hikaru and
now
knights the e2 knight f3 is the the main
line here there are
like 2500 games in the database from top
tier games but 92
second most popular idea this is what
magnus goes so goes for we have
d5 and now a3 only challenging the
bishop now we have captures captures and
here hikaru trades captures captures
and queen to c7 preparing b6 bishop to
a6 and so on
the usual names of indian stuff and here
uh the usual
thing to do is to move the bishop to d3
as you are expecting captures here and
you don't want your bishop to be under
attack so here
magnus doesn't go for bishop d3 but
rather bishop back to a2
he's going to bring this bishop to b2
and he wants to get his
bishop pair uh to be fully operational
we have b6 by hikaru and
magnus just castles we have bishop to a6
now
putting pressure on the knight here and
bishop to b2 and now
knight the c6 nicely continuing
development connecting rooks
uh and uh preparing to to bring them
into the game we have rooked the c one
by magnus and here
uh there there are there are games where
rook after d8 was played also knight
the a5 is a known move but here rook ate
the c8 the movie car
place is a new move so now already as of
move 13 we have a completely new game
so c4 by magnus uh and now comes c
capture sunday for we have e capture on
d4 and yes you're expecting d5 you don't
want to allow captures captures
for the rook to be staring at your queen
so queen e7
uh but magnus goes for d5 uh
you know uh just the same and it's very
interesting because it's upon sacrifice
because after he
captures it's impossible to recapture
because of bishop characters here just
winning material
uh so instead after this e captures and
b5 we have rook to e1 by magnus so
very very interesting pawn sacrifice
bishop captures on c4 he car
grabs yet another pawn and now magnus
goes for knights the g3 opens up an
attack towards the queen
queen the e8 and now bishop back to b1
of course you don't want to trade a
trade off your bishop you just
sacrifice two pawns for the attack and
now what what do you have well you are
somewhat better developed but that's
also to be seen you do have a very
nicely placed
bishop pair not yet a bishop pair from
hell but it is a nice bishop here
and well black has no direct way of
trading off any pieces so here we have
b5 by hikaru strengthening that bishop
preparing d4 uh and knight to f5 now
bringing your pieces towards uh
towards your opponent's king we have d
for now that the bishop is nicely
defended
this cuts off the dark square bishop's
diagonal and now queen to d2 preparing
queen g5 to put some pressure on the g7
pawn
we have bishop back the e6 by hikaru now
preparing to capture the knight here and
just
rook the c5 saying that okay i want to
capture
i'm just going to recapture i'm going to
have a nicely positioned rook here
and here even though that well that
might be so
capturing capturing here is probably the
way to go just capture
even better capture with the bishop as
white would maybe want to double rooks
along the c file uh would be the way to
go for hikaru however hikaru just played
a6 he said
nah there aren't any any dangers here uh
but there
there are some so uh feel free to pause
the video here and figure out
the dangers in the position while i
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations i'm spotting
the uh the excellent attacking move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
knight characters and g7 point being the
queen is ready to jump here
and now the well black doesn't really
have a better move other than capturing
the knight so this is what hikaru goes
for
with queen g5 check king the h8 and now
how do you continue the attack
well there are some ideas but magnus
goes for the
most uh difficult to calculate one which
is queen to h4
queen to h4 uh just uh
putting the queen to an excellent square
preparing some rook lifts uh the bishops
are also very nicely placed uh you can
also bring the rook into the game
via this as the knight doesn't really
have all that many ways
but your main threat is to capture the
knight on c6 basically you want to
remove the defender of the d4 pawn
capture here
the queen from h4 also nicely attacks
the pawn and then you want your dark
square bishop to be able to be able to
go for the black king
and here hikaru was much better on time
hiker was some six minutes on the clock
whereas magnus was three
but here on this move he carl burned all
of his time trying to figure out a way
out of this mess
and you can't really blame him because
the only way out of this mess
is the seemingly impossible to calculate
rook to e8 and
why this is a way out well this is a
this is a
completely disgusting engine line
defense which i'm just going to show
it's it would be inhuman to expect
someone to find this in a rapid game
but uh you know we're still going to
show it as it's just beautiful
so rook the e8 and now the idea of rook
captures removing the defender of the
pawn
rook captures and bishop captures
attacking this uh
doesn't work because of the move bishop
to f5 now this
uh now the knight is nicely defended and
also you're threatening
checkmate here so after captures with
check you're going to play king to g8
and
white doesn't have time to capture the
queen because the rook captures hero
with mate
so queen g5 check you can block with the
bishop bishop g6
again mate being threatened so you have
to trade it off with
czech queen captures again black
threatens mate and now you have to make
some breeding room for the king
but now h6 uh pushing the queen back and
once the queen moves let's say queen to
f4 now you can pick up the
the bishop here and then after queen
captures an h6 again threatening
checkmate
now you go for queen to e1 check king to
h2
and now the incredible queen e5 check uh
forcing a trade here either winning the
bishop or forcing a queen trait captures
captures
and we ended this with uh black being
upper rook so
this is not a force line but it is one
of the lines that that can happen
if uh after this rook the e8 white
persists with the idea of rook
characters on c6
uh so really really incredible stuff
hikaru tried a different idea he played
rook g8 with the idea of shifting the
king over here to
where it's safe and now magnus just goes
for it rook captures on c6 now the idea
works real captures and just bishop
captures on d4 sorry wrong bishop
uh and now king the g7 bishop to f5 was
still very strong here
uh because the rook now defends uh at
the knight as well
and here we will probably see bishop
captures and now now of course you do
not want a blunder queen h7 checkmate
the knight is pinned
so you have to block with the rook and
now after captures captures
uh we would continue this position with
the material on the board being
completely equal
with white of course being better as i
mean look at black's position
uh however hikaru continued with king to
g7
and now magnus goes for it queen
captures an h7 check the knight of
course is pinned king f8 and queen h6
check again going for the knight
king e8 uh now offering the knight uh if
you try to go king to e7
uh to defend the knight it's not much
better i mean now the queen no longer
defends it so after queen
uh queen h6 check king d8 we have
captures on f6
and now queen to a5 moving the queen
with the threat of checkmate so
queen the e3 and now queen back to b6 he
karuna wants to trade queens as his king
is a very
very exposed here and now magnus
instantly played rook to d1
saying okay i have you i have you
completely pinned down because if queen
captures rook to the eighth
checkmate however uh hikaru laughed in
his face
and he just played rook to b6 saying
nope you're the one with backrank
weaknesses and now the point is if
magnus goes for the queen
rook captures his checkmate and the
other thing you could do
uh well you could trade queens captures
captures but then uh all your
well ammunition is basically gone you
still have the bishop fair you're still
going to play h4 make some
bringing room for your king but uh well
most of your
advantage would be gone but white should
still be better
so after bishop so after this rook to d6
magnus decided not to trade anything he
played bishop to d4
and now we have a queen to c6 by hikaru
we have bishop to e4 going after the
queen and now queen to c4
putting more pressure on the bishop here
with h3 finally magnus creates some
breeding room for the king and
king to d7 now getting the king away
from the e file
and preparing to bring the other rook
into the game we have rook to d2
uh and uh now uh preparing for either a
rook lift would rook to c2 but also the
rook is just nicely defending everything
along the second rank
and also if the bishop moves uh the rook
is nicely protected
so rook the eq by hikaru the correct way
to play this is
by going uh either rook to d8 or rook to
c8 as
you wanna be able to hide your king
behind the rook
however uh here we have rooked the ia by
hicaru and now
magnus is the one who can uh who can
force a win
but it's not easy to spot it uh here you
you
win the well maybe maybe you even want
to try and
and win this position uh all right give
it a try we'll give you a couple of
seconds
uh so for those of you who are able to
find it congratulations as it's a move
magnus missed
so for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop to e5 this
just wins the rook
as the rook has nowhere to go all of
these squares are covered by the bishop
pair
and of course if you trade then just
queen a7 check and wherever you go
you're getting checkmated king c8 you're
getting queen b7 check if you go here
bishop f6 is checked
no moves for the king you have to trade
and now it's captures king c8 and the
queen b7 checkmate the bishop covers
this
so this is what would happen if bishop
to e5 was played however magnus decided
to improve his position first
and now bishop to d5 by hikaru now rook
the c8
with the ability to block any incoming
checks from the queen it was the way to
go however
hikaru played bishop to d5 and now comes
bishop to f5
with check so uh hikaru blocks again he
wants to trade but now
bishop to d3 check attacking the queen
queen back to a4
and now now magnus found the move that
you all found in the previous pausing of
the video
here magnus played bishop to e5 and now
the queen has
clear access into the position uh with
queen to a7 check
so there's not much you can do you can
either start giving
more material or you can play something
hikaru played something which is rook d5
but now queen a7
checked and it was in this position that
hikaru nakamura resigned the game and
game one of match six goes to magnus
cross and who is one step closer
of equalizing the result uh in the
in the overall match so here you resign
because either king
d8 or king c8 or king what
king c6 are met with queen to c7 which
will be checkmate there are no other
moves so whatever you play queen c7 is
checkmate
and that's just it so really really
awesome attacking game by magnus uh
that uh i mean that was uh some
very serious home preparation in such a
traditional line of the nimzo indian
with white to find such a beautiful
double pawn sacrifice to employ the
the bishop heir from hell uh really
really really awesome and
where better to to use such a novelty uh
than
uh you know in in the finals of such a
prestigious and you know pricey
tournament that is the magnus calls and
chess tour
so that's the game i do hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank
frank lebano uh nike store uh evgeny
brisken david uh
elkhoff uh and franz hilber for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos uh here
uh thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
magnus carlsen
chester final checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day